first I just like to obviously thank
numb focus and pie data for accepting
this tool really excited to be able to
talk to you all about it this morning
and Who am I I'm George Richardson you
can find me at various places on the
Internet and this talk is really going
to kind of be a story about how I ended
getting up how I ended up being involved
with this project a little bit about the
details of the project itself and then
some kind of things about datafeed
democracy and getting involved with this
kind of work yourselves and about a year
ago I was a physicist I spent my time in
a dark room with lasers as my only
friends and I kind of decided I had
enough of that and took a change of
direction so that's how I've ends up
here but of course for this audience my
story is much better described with a
graph so I went back into my long-term
memory ran a ran a query and pulled out
my sense of purpose over time it was
even 0 to 5 years there's not really any
data there some kind of legacy system is
obviously being used and but we kind of
had this flatline through childhood I
don't read even though we know if we
know what sense of purposes throughout
kids throughout our childhood we hid
this kind of peek of teenage arrogance
around 15 years old and then it tapers
off through my undergrad degree as I
kind of lose sight of what I'm really
doing with my life and then it Peaks
during my PhD just at the start where I
think science academia this is me I
could do this forever before I start
spending all that time in the darkroom
with the lasers and it plummets to an
all-time low but during this time I
spent some time probably a process that
lots of people in this room have been
through I started to learn how to code a
bit and just start playing with some
data and hauling some graphs and doing
some visualizations and then someone in
the end I found out that that was
actually a thing that people wanted you
to be able to do and so things started
to look up and I took a journey that I'm
sure many of you are familiar with but I
always had this cite one of the things I
wasn't happy about with my PhD was that
I wanted to work on problems that were
more tangible had a bigger impact on the
kind of challenges that I was interested
in and so I kept this in mind whilst
learning these new skills and wound up
with data for democracy
so data for democracy it's just a
loose-knit group of kind of civic minded
technologists data people developers we
have domain experts we have data
officers from government in there and we
spread across the globe
and we're connected by nothing more than
a big slack team and a shared github
repository and we work on all kinds of
projects a lot of it is related to
democracy and kind of election so we
have gerrymandering election
transparency and looking at government
expenditures but it also branches out
into other areas so we have hate speech
and people just building generic
open-source data processing tools to
kind of enable this kind of work and
some of the work is just purely
community driven and some of it comes
from external stimulus and it was back
in February when Jonathan Morgan who
kind of set the whole data for democracy
thing up for this project to my
attention so it was a competition set up
by unite ideas which is a kind of UN
innovation wing and they were trying to
help the Internal Displacement
monitoring center figure out a better
way of tracking displaced people and
this project really excited me so I
volunteered to chordae a team and we
went on to put together a solution which
actually ultimately ended up winning the
competition which was announced a couple
of weeks ago and we were really happy
about that so I want to tell you about
that project but first just a little bit
about displacement so an internally
displaced person is someone who is
fleeing from conflict or violence or
oppression or a natural disaster but who
is trapped within their own country so
there are particularly vulnerable people
because they are still under the
protection of a government that might be
committing as violence against them or a
government that is reeling from the same
disaster that they are suffering from so
it's really important to help these
people out in 2016 the final count was
about 40 million internally displaced
people worldwide with 7 million new
displacements due to conflict and
violence and about 24 million due to
disaster it didn't jump from 10 to 30
million from 10 million to 40 million in
one year you
you have people who are internally
displaced to become refugees or maybe
they're reabsorbed back into communities
or they go on and seek asylum elsewhere
and we can also see in this map of the
world that's not showing up at all the
the conflict and conflict based
displacements are sensitive in Africa
and Middle East and in Central America
just use your imaginations and and
whereas this has to based displacement
to kind of spread across the world and
how is this monitored at moment well the
IBM scene internal displacement
monitoring center use an array of tools
they use things like satellite imagery
analysis they have dynamic risk modeling
that they do and they also analyze a
flood of articles that come in every day
that might be reporting on displacement
events around the world now all of these
methods are necessary to corroborate
each other and to work with the
different partners that they have but
the problem is they're very
labor-intensive so satellite imagery a
lot of this is done by hand
someone poring over images and marking
them and checking them and showing them
to someone else and then again with this
flood of articles and news reports that
come in every day they use a method they
call human natural language processing
now that's not natural language
processing that's so good it's almost
human that's just people sitting in a
room literally reading these articles
every day and trying to contact help
them and so this is the part that they
really wanted help with they want to
free up these analysts to do more
important work so they wanted an
automated tool that could collect
articles it could classify them as to
whether they're about conflict or
disaster and then to extract the key
information from them so the
displacement figure location dates
things like that and they wanted this to
all be done in kind of one tool they
could wrap up and plug into their system
into their monitoring suite and so
that's what we tried to do so I'll tell
you a little bit about our approach to
give you an idea of how we did it so the
first part is this data collection and
this is really just web scraping they
have a flood of URLs that are coming in
every day and they want to get the
information from them so for the
competition they just provided a CSV CSV
in CSV out that's fine but we thought
well
want to plug this into their database
system later we need to build something
a little bit more flexible so is that
some post aggressive structure and used
SQL alchemy to interface with that the
challenge really came when we needed to
access the URLs and extract the content
from them so I don't know if some of you
might have used tools like scrapey or
beautifulsoup
or you've heard about them for scraping
and they're fantastic tools I've used
myself
and but they're really great if you know
exactly which elements from a webpage
you want to get the problem is is that
displacement reports come in from all
over the world through all different
sources from all different domains so it
might be report aggregation websites or
newspapers from all different parts of
the world and we didn't have the time to
write individual scrapers for each one
of those sites and to look through and
see which tags would come up and who
knows what then be in the test data
after that but luckily there's a
lesser-known module out there called
newspaper there's a really cool little
package and what it does is it uses a
lot of cases to infer what what the
information on the page is that you
might want to pull out and it is super
easy to use you simply feed it a URL you
feed it into an article cross in
newspaper and then you can download it
and pass it and then query it for the
information that you want you can get
the title the text the publication date
the authors it is super super handy it
doesn't work in every single case but we
were happy to almost just stop there and
we didn't really make a whole lot of
more modifications to that and because
it does such a good job so I really
recommend you check that out now the
next part once we've got this content is
to classify it and then to extract the
information so as you probably guess
this is a natural language processing
problem so how many people in here have
done any kind of NLP okay a few people
and I assume some people went to the NLP
I think it was a tutorial yesterday so I
like this description here it's around
everything it says NLP is way for
computers to analyze understand and
derive meaning from human language and
the smartness for white and that's
exactly what we're going to try to do so
what does this look like in practice
well normally you have a collection of
documents or tweets or emails or angry
Amazon reviews or god forbid posts from
four channel
read it I mean you can analyze them you
can analyze them at the document level
you can split them up and analyze them
at the sentence or the paragraph level
and then you can break that down even
further and analyze them at the word or
in NLP language the token level does
anyone know where that quotes from yeah
I think it perfectly describes data
science and what do we have in Python to
do this work with well there's an array
of tools that we can work with but what
I found very confusing when I first
started doing NLP was that nobody really
explains there's kind of a spectrum of
ways you can tackle NLP problems on the
one hand we have this this kind of
linguistic rules based approach where we
do things like pre-processing parsing we
tag the nouns and the verbs in a
sentence --is and then on the other end
what's what's more coming to the fore
point today is the kind of numerical
approaches so where we try to find
numerical representations of language
and then do stuff like machine learning
and deep learning with them and so on on
the Left we have things package like NL
TK on the right we have scikit-learn and
Genting and space he's kind of cool
because in the middle it can it can kind
of do a bit of both and so that's what
we've got let's have a look at the kind
of text that we were looking at so this
is one text this is an excerpt from an
article and I can highlight the kind of
the key information for you there we can
see that it's we can imagine that it's
not going to be too difficult to get a
computer to figure out what this article
is about
we have words about storms and flooding
disaster water water so we can probably
infer that it's about disaster natural
disaster we have lots of mentions at
places in America and we have a mention
of a number of people who have been
displaced and we have a date
so that's not too difficult but then let
me show you another excerpt from a
slightly longer article and I'll
highlight the key information can
anybody see what might be the problems
here
okay I'll point our couple so first we
have some very militaristic words in the
first few sentences words like
deployment based choppers and combat so
if we just kind of let computer blind we
kind of stumble into this article it
might start to think that it's about
come
selected based displacement rather than
disaster displaced is based displacement
and we also have multiple displacement
events in this in this excerpt we have
thousands of different people evacuated
from different places on different dates
so this is kind of the other end of the
spectrum the more challenging kind of
cases that we had to deal with
so first the classification problem we
need to classify the articles as
conflict disaster or other and obviously
we're going to go with a kind of gener'l
data science workflow where we build
some kind of model and then later on
with with tagged articles and then later
on we feed in unclassified articles and
see if we can infer which class they
fall into so first we went with a really
simple rules based approach just to see
what we could do we just scan through
some articles manually and we started to
pick out tokens that we thought
represented what they would be about so
we had a bunch of conflict tokens and a
bunch of disaster tokens then we just
used a simple counting algorithm to see
which which the which words kind of fell
into these articles the most and then
see if we classify them and we actually
didn't do too badly
we have f1 scores that are not terrible
but probably not amazing considering
we're working with human life critical
data so we obviously started to move
towards some some more advanced stuff
and we M we use the kind of more
numerical methods so first you can you
can build up a term frequency matrix I
think I think a lot of this was covered
yesterday you can build up a term
frequency matrix where you count the
occurrences of every word in your
documents and these are just completely
made-up documents and numbers and and
that's okay but it doesn't really tell
you about the importance of the words so
90% of those articles might contain the
word people and they all have lots high
counts of the word people in them but
that doesn't really help you figure out
whether the articles about conflict or
displacement or or disaster and so what
you can do is transfer this matrix into
a term frequency inverse document
frequency matrix where the rarer words
in your entire corpus of documents are
given a higher weighting so words like
combat or flooding which will only
appear in a fraction of the documents
will be boosted in this matrix here
that's good now we have a pretty decent
feature space that we can start
analyzing our documents with but again
we still have a bunch of kind of
irrelevant terms in there and this this
is going to be a large fraction of the
English vocabulary so it's going to be
very sparse it's a sparse matrix with
lots of empty space so finally we can do
some dimensionality reduction on this
which is a method by which we we shrink
the dimensions about matrix but we
retain most of the patterns in the
information and and what we end up with
is is columns that represent what are
called topics so kind of a mishmash of
words with with different weightings
given to them and again these are
totally made-up but we might have a
topic about that's mostly about flooding
and fleeing one it's about vehicles and
combat and then some more generic topics
and this is a method known as latent
semantic indexing and this is a method
we used and we've trained some machine
learning models on it and with about
hundred dimensions we achieved f1 scores
that were very similar to just taking a
keyword approach and and you can see
over here when we project down onto two
dimensions that the disaster in the
conflict articles are kind of separated
but we have this big wedge of articles
that could be about something else in
the middle and it's kind of a lot of
bleed in between the classes and but
what we ended up doing is taking this
keyword approach and the machine
learning approach and combining them
together and building up some kind of
rules and running through lots of
different cases and finally wind up with
some scores that we thought were kind of
pretty decent so that's the article
classification part now we have the
information extraction we need to figure
out when these people were displaced how
many of them there were and we need to
understand the reporting terms and the
reporting units which are kind of the
action words to do with the displacement
and to figure out whether we're just
talking about individual people or
multiple families to try and get an
estimate of the size the size of people
of people that have been displaced now
as I showed you before one article can
contain multiple displacement events so
we need to figure out a way of scanning
through these documents to try to
extract those individual reports the
first thing we just tried to do is we
took our list of reporting terms and
reporting units and looked for sentences
where they Co occurred and
that works pretty well but it also gives
you a lot of irrelevant data and it's
kind of difficult to actually come up
with an exhaustive list of key terms
that's the real problem with this the
dis approach but what we found when we
used Spacey and we did some part of
speech tagging is that the reporting
terms almost always the verb in the
sentence and the reporting unit the the
bit we cared about was always be always
the object or the subject of that verb
so just using some kind of basic
linguistic rules we were suddenly able
to narrow down our rules for searching
for sentences and we were able to pretty
successfully pull out most of the
reports from it from every article that
we had and layer on it's not too
difficult to use something like Spacey
to actually just extract the information
from those sentences and this is just
basically matched up with a kind of neat
tool called displace you which helps you
just visually check on what's going on
when you're running through these these
sentences but we have another problem
here when we're just using this
linguistic approach we might have
sentences that don't fall in to our list
of keywords as I mentioned before so
here I just made up the sentence that
has citizens and move to safety none of
those are cleared in the list of terms
giving us given to us by the ID MC so
again I'm not going to go massively into
depth on this but I think going into
word Tyvek is a bit beyond the scope of
this talk but we use some things like
word Tyvek and some word vectorization
and Billups and bigram dictionaries and
to build a kind of much richer numerical
description of the sentences that we've
managed to extract from each article and
again we were able to apply a rule that
combined the rules-based approach and
the machine learning approach and get a
boost to our f1 school and these all fed
into this large program that we built
and it was really exciting because we
ended up working with a team of
volunteers who had just come together
who had never met each other before and
just started hacking away on this
program and it turned into something
bigger than any of us imagined I really
thought it would just be me with a
couple of Jupiter notebooks there for a
few weeks just kind of hacking away on
my own but it turned into something much
bigger and by the end of it we had
people volunteering to build out a
graphical user interface build some in
visualizations and build kind of
interactive maps and it's just kind of
grew into this amazing thing
and like I said we went on to win the
competition and ultimately it was the
machine learning approach that they
really liked because it can evolve with
the situations on the ground as the
nature of displacement changes and the
language that people use to talk about
it changes this will also be able to
evolve with that situation and there's
also a clear cry out for more open
source development on this kind of work
to tackle these kind of problems from
the UN and the good news is that we're
now working directly with the IBMC
they've they've been in touch with us
and we're actually building our solution
into their toolkit and we're going to
try to move them from human NLP to human
computer NLP and the one extra bit I
didn't really mention is that we're now
also building in kind of ways for the
human analysts to interact with this
program and verify the results because
this isn't like recommending a movie to
someone you know it doesn't matter too
much if you recommend someone finding
Nemo when they really wanted Mad Max
fury road but it does matter if you get
the number of displaced people wrong or
the location wrong or you know human
lives depend on it so there has to be a
way the humans are still going to work
for this data and look at it and check
it so we're kind of packaging this all
up and working with them and over the
next few months we're hoping to
implement it into their monitoring suite
and we're really happy to be doing that
so I just want to share with you a few
reflections about working the data for
democracy and kind of being able to get
into doing this kind of work yourselves
you come to this talk I'm sure you're
all interested in in tackling these
kinds of issues so I reached out to the
wider community and kind of we had a bit
of a chat and just got some feedback and
and this came back from multiple
projects so the first thing is form
alliances so a lot of projects have
started out in its kind of exploratory
data analysis method and kind of looking
at datasets that are out there and
digging around and trying to find
insights and that's great but eventually
you kind of you'll run out steam this
isn't your area of expertise you need
someone who can help guide those
questions I think it's something that we
all know but it really comes to light
when you're working on these really
complex global challenges building
external partnerships is also important
just to have some kind of motor
patience to keep you going some goals
people to set deadlines and and for you
to be able to see the impact of your
results directly to know there's someone
on the other end of it who's pleased
with your work and wants to see it
continue and I mean you really can just
reach out to people in this most people
want this kind of help and they like
talking about their own work so reach
out see what you can find despite saying
that just just do something like if
there's a problem you want to tackle
nobody else and you've got an idea for
it nobody else is going to lay down
those lines of first lines of code for
you you need to be the first person to
do that and other people will get on
board out so that you guarantee you and
if you can't figure out exactly how
you're going to tackle the problem just
look at data just start collecting data
there's no shortage of the need for
people to just gather interesting
datasets about about problems that we
don't have enough information about and
finally everyone in data doctoral C
agrees you need to make this fun like do
it in a minute area you're interested
about don't just follow something
because it seems like a kind of a
challenge or just just purely for that
reason because eventually you'll run out
of steam pick pick a topic and
passionate about and go with it and try
to do with a community that that can
support you there's there's Code for
America Brigade there's data kind
there's data for democracy lots of
cities have their own open civic tech
brigades you can kind of join up with
and find I had to do that I didn't have
any data science friends to work with
myself and an in date that's a slight
error but nevermind in data democracy we
have a few extra things that we think
make it fun for the kiss specific
community so it's a loose collective of
people who are just kind of they're
ready to be civically engaged on these
activities you can kind of always reach
out to them in it's a big support group
we don't have any rules
no-one's tell you what projects to do is
it's very open we just have guidelines
that were slowly building as a community
to try and constantly improve these
projects and as one of our members Ben
said it's kind of like the open source
model applied civic good which I really
like and so you should tackle government
and tackle these global challenges for
every person out there tackling these
big global problems with data science
there's a thousand people trying to sell
more crap
that people don't need so if you want to
work on big challenges that
differentiate yourselves there's never
been a better time to work on projects
with civic social environmental impact
now I don't think what we did was super
sophisticated anything is beyond what
anybody in this room did but we did it
and I think it just goes to show that
anyone in this room with the abilities
that you have can make an absolutely
massive impact so I just want to thank
everybody else who worked on this
project in data democracy and the entire
community I also want to thank just give
a shout out to CrowdFlower because they
gave us some credits to help tags and
some extra data that was really useful
to us and and finally if you live in
Seattle and you want to get directly
involved we have a kind of casual data
for democracy hang out at galvanize on
Mondays but you can come along too and I
am Co organizing a social Civic good
mixer thing that's coming up on July the
22nd where we're actually trying to
build partnerships we're trying to get
nonprofits and community organizations
along with technologists into the same
room to actually meet each other and
start these kind of discussions about
what kind of innovation and projects we
can we can bring to light and with that
I'd just like to thank you all very much
for listening
[Applause]
for coming and talking to us about data
democracy does anyone have any questions
said um like how many people were
displaced where so what sort of
granularity is it which country or like
which region how deep because I think
from the articles how is it like how do
you match like that region is in India
and you know they're cities of the same
name how did you tackle that yeah that's
a really interesting question it's one I
don't think we've completely closed and
and I'm not sure how the IDM sea tackle
at the moment geo tagging was a whole
other part of this project that I didn't
really get into it is a problem
ultimately what I want it as grant as
granular as possible but from some of
the articles you can see that's just not
possible sometimes you'll get something
that comes in and says floods in India
you know often in in in countries like
the US or the UK
you just get newspaper articles and
they'll talk about something happening
in the pool and the pool is a big place
it doesn't tell you exactly where so
yeah it's a struggle and I think almost
the challenge here is part of it is to
pinpoint displacement events and
displacement figures and things like
that
but part of it is also just to track the
reporting of these events and to kind of
gather evidence on that phenomenon
itself as well but yeah it's a problem
and we we haven't completely solved it
how do you deal with duplicate data like
if there's an article or multiple
articles and do you mean exactly the
same article or the same report
occurring from two different sites the
same report from do different sites and
so if if it comes in from two different
sites we and it's a night it's identical
text we would try to track that and we
would try to not double count the
displacement however if you have reports
coming in from different places that
have been made by different people
that's actually benefit because that's
corroboration of that event going on so
we're actually currently building ways
to kind of cluster articles and figure
out whether they actually supporting
each other in terms of evidence hey
there a quick question for you sorry
over here he doubled up the mics um yeah
quick question could you you kind of
talked a little bit about this but what
are some of your follow-on projects and
for this work for this work specifically
and so right now it's it's simply
working with the ID MC to integrate that
into their system I think and what we'd
really like to do is get more training
data that the training dataset wasn't
that huge because it required human
analysts to sit down and create it and
so I think we've got a long way to go
with the model improvement and then
really it's building in this kind of and
human verification and then an ability
to do some kind of online learning with
the algorithms so that it's it's
continuously updating so how do you
tackle the publication's from different
languages because sometimes all the
events would be in local languages
straight in different parts of the world
did you look at that or just we do
everything we just looked at articles in
English for the time being but in the
long term that's for sure where this has
to go there are a lot of articles in
Spanish and for example that we we
didn't manage to classify yeah okay
thanks hi you have it any plan to
support other language support other
language obvious I think that was
similar is in those languages of the
articles
yes yeah yeah in the long term that's
definite that we have to do that yeah
thanks
it's like we have one more here how did
you deal with inaccurate reports and you
know data that could be misconstrued or
you know looked at and you know it could
be you know inaccurate reports yeah and
to be honest that wasn't agile at this
stage but it's something we're now in
conversation with and I'm not sure whose
benefit is to report inaccurate in this
but but it does happen I think
ultimately that's where having the array
of different different monitoring
methods comes in I think there's always
going to be inaccurate reporting
something we had to deal with find and
figure out way of dealing with was when
an article says thousands or hundreds or
dozens you know what does that actually
mean how how do we deal with that and
there's all kinds of methods such as
looking at the average household size in
that region and all working with
satellite imagery to try and you know
refine the results a little bit yeah
good question does anyone else have any
questions
I just this is more with data for
democracy how how do you go about
scaling and production arising some of
the solutions you felt for them and then
in terms of like the funding for putting
those for production rising it how did
that all go about yeah so the question
was about how do we production eyes kind
of projects from data for democracy and
that's actually an emerging question at
the moment because it's it's only been
going for six months and I think we're
starting to get to that point and
there's the possibility now for
resources for this project which is
which is fantastic and but yeah most
people doing out their own pockets and
we're just slowly figuring out for a lot
of people working data democracy myself
included this was the first time we'd
ever worked on collaborative projects
and we'd had to you know use a
collaborative github workflow and so
there's it's just a really a group
effort of figuring out how to do that
and then making sure we record best
practices on how to go further in it
we're just kind of all edging ahead and
figuring it out from each other yeah
rowella take oh one last question from
the back here
you mentioned interactive maps briefly
at the end and I was curious if you talk
to us a bit about your visualization to
us yeah we we kind of built well one of
our members yane he built a this
interactive map which it was very
similar to the map that I showed near
the start with the kind of the large
circles on a global map that gives you
an idea of how many displacements there
there are and how big they are and when
they've occurred in time so you could
scan scan through time and that was
really something more for us to showcase
the project than anything else and we've
now kind of after talking to the IDM see
a lot more they have a vision for their
own visualizations which is not entirely
clear to me right now but I think they
have a very specific way they've been
thinking about this problem for a long
time and ultimately this is about
convincing stakeholders to act on on the
problem and I think they've spent a lot
of time thinking about the best ways of
doing that and we're kind of ready to
listen to them on that yeah I'd love to
be able to figure out how they're going
to do that all right well I'd like to
thank George again for coming to talk to
us we all come around applause
mark